let's forget about the specs and go
straight into real world use and i'll
put it right out there
the note 20 is a much better phone than
the iphone 11 pro max
so much so that it hurts me going back
to the iphone
after using the note it's been two weeks
since i got it in
and in this video i'll share exactly
what i love about the note 20
and the few things that keep me from
switching over completely
but with that said i am right there on
the edge and may end up ditching apple
i'll explain why in just a bit i'll also
mention why i think that the note 20
ultra is a much better phone than the
s20 ultra let's start out with the look
and feel in the hand
my iphone has a large six and a half
inch display which is big but the note
20 ultras is 6.9 inches
which may not seem like a big difference
but in the real world
trust me you definitely notice it a big
reason is the camera cutout is very
small instead of a large notch
and the corners of the screen are barely
curved and with tiny bezels
going back to the iphone feels outdated
now at this point i would also
ditch face id for three reasons first
the notch it requires is
ugly second face id is a pain to use
during these kova times
and no you cannot register your face
with a mask on
and third is that samsung's under
display fingerprint tech has gotten
super fast and reliable
believe it or not the note 20 is also
actually more comfortable to hold in the
hand
it is taller but it's actually slightly
narrower and
the super slim frame makes it feel
slimmer
my biggest complaint with the s20 was
the thickness and the weight
not only did samsung slim it down but
also
lowered the weight which makes it feel
lighter in the hand than the 11 pro max
especially against that chunky s20 ultra
now with that thinning the camera bump
had to get thicker
but that change was actually for the
good as my finger can actually rest
there
and help support the phone instead of
just digging into
my finger like the s20 does and to top
it off i love how the notes
bottom and top is flat which is perfect
since i tend to rest my finger there
to support the weight overall if you
spend a lot of time holding your phone
responding to emails and doing other
things it is definitely
more comfortable than the iphone now
speaking of productivity i try to get
used to the s pen
and force myself to use it but once
again it is just
not for me so it just stays in the phone
pretty much all the time
now with this gorgeous display i am
still
having auto brightness issues maybe the
iphone just nails it all the time
or i'm used to its algorithm but the
samsung phones need more tweaking
especially in dimmer lighting one thing
that keeps shocking me
every time i pick up and use the note 20
are the speakers wow
do they sound good i was expecting the
same speakers from the s20
but no samsung made a bunch of changes
to them
and here just take a listen
[Music]
they're still loud like the s20s which i
love but now the sound is much more rich
and full
and it's more balanced for stereo
listening on top of the sound quality
improvements the back of the phone has
way less vibrations when you're
listening at full volume
which was a big complaint with the s20
ultra
with that comes the media experience and
it's really good
pairing these speakers to that gorgeous
6.9 inch widescreen oled makes for some
great video watching
and the square display edges and the
tiny cutout is so much nicer than the
iphone since that notch is gone
in the video especially widescreen video
fills almost the whole screen
i do have to point out two downsides
first
it really bugs me if i'm watching a
video with the phone on the desk
the note 20s camera bump really just
makes it lay flat and kind of
awkward and that's kind of annoying
second is that with ios 14 my iphone's
hdr does pop a little bit more now
before it is actually worse and i can
stream in 4k
which finally makes the video look just
as good as the notes
detail-wise with its high-res screen but
this is where i have to get into
a huge issue with my iphone when i'm on
the go
i can't ever use that 4k streaming
option or even 1440p
heck most of the time i can't even do
1080p even if i have good lte service
now i know this depends on your city and
how busy the networks are
but there is no doubt that the note 20s
5g
is way faster and that's just using sub
6
not the millimeter wave ultra fast 5g
yesterday with full bars 1080p would
just buffer on the iphone for me
so i did a speed test and it got 6.2
megabits per second i popped the sim
into the note 20 and streamed 1440p
video perfectly earlier in the day i
actually tested at the office and my
iphone got 13.7 megabits per second
while the note 20 got 59.
this data speed is noticeable and it's
not something that not very many
reviewers actually talk about
if you're in a city with faster speeds
the note will still be about twice
as fast as the iphone at least in all of
my testing
now back to the screens i ended up going
back to the higher quality 60 fps mode
after a few days of using 120 hertz
now it is really nice but having text
being noticeably softer than the iphone
it really started to bug me the note has
very fast animation so even using it at
60 hertz it feels snappier than the
iphone
but i really wish that we could have a
combo of the high res
and the faster refresh rate now the a13
bionic
is faster button and two to the note is
actually better for
graphics and memory speeds and for
gaming the note 20
is really nice especially because of the
larger
more full display i noticed no drop
frames or stuttering
gaming was super smooth and enjoyable
one major difference that's really
starting to
literally make me mad with my iphone
is background apps the note 20's 12 gigs
of ram
keeps my apps open seemingly forever
whereas the iphone's 4 gigabyte is
frustrating
especially the times where i go to take
a photo and an app that i was just using
closes now the battery did seem to drain
faster than the iphones
even though it's a little bit bigger at
4 500 milliamp hours compared to just
under 4 000 for the iphone 11 pro max
but i would say i got about an
hour less screen on time and that's
using the high res
display mode and having that always on
display the s20 ultra
has a 5 000 milliamp hour battery but i
would gladly
trade that for the slimmer chassis of
the note 20
especially because charging is so fast
it takes about an hour from an
empty battery compared to about two
hours with the iphone
using its 18 watt fast charger it also
tops off
much faster because the iphone takes
about an hour and a half to get from 50
to 100 whereas the note takes only about
30 minutes
and now let's talk about the cameras and
i have to say
they are great this is what samsung
wanted to achieve
with the s20 ultras but they failed at
part of this is software optimizations
but the other part is the laser
autofocusing edition
and because of it the autofocusing was
great on this
phone i literally didn't have a single
time that i noticed
that something messed up which happened
quite often on the s20 ultra
comparing the photos to the iphone they
are at times neck and neck when using
the main sensors
but when using the ultrawide or the
telephoto the note 20 looks
much more detailed i know that apple
won't put in the same kind of super zoom
lens in the next iphone but i really
wish they would because you get just
so much more detail for those shots the
other massive difference is you could do
night mode shots with the ultra wide
and the front-facing camera which makes
it look so much
better and actually usable instead of
being horrible they have to throw away
on the iphone
as far as the video the iphone still
looks better and it could do 4k 60 with
any of the cameras the note 20 did
improve over the s20 and it looks good
it also has 8k but it's still mostly
unusable in that mode because of shake
and it barely looks better than the 4k
now i have said a lot of positives for
the note 20 but there are some negatives
i think the biggest one is samsung's
skin it's not a deal breaker but i much
prefer the pixel phones
the oneplus and of course ios as far as
being a modern look and feel
and of course we have that big
difference between ios and
android both have their pluses and
minuses
but right now i am moved back to the
iphone because of my apple watch
my mac and icloud with imessage but i'm
still
right there at the edge of switching and
i know people say hey
stop using imessage as an excuse and
icloud but to be
honest if most of your friends and
family have iphones and you're sharing
videos and images you're sharing icloud
links and using that it's just so
convenient compared to switching over
to a samsung or an android phone and
sending out photos that get compressed
like crazy through text or
having to force yourself to use other
services especially with older people
the note 20 is a much better phone
overall than the iphone
and it's interesting that finally after
so many years it is
apple that is playing catch-up every
year instead of
samsung if the iphone 12 does not
fix some of these big issues i think i
will permanently have to become an
android user let me know your thoughts
down below and if you like our videos go
ahead and pick up a max
tech shirt or maybe one of these awesome
face masks
in our merch shelf down below or that
link thank you guys for watching this
been max
and i will see you in the next video